les gens les plus forts de cette planète
c'est les gens qui sont capables de se
modérer un carré de
chocolat je savais même pas qu'il y
avait des
carrés pour moi il y avait un
rectangle avec des décorations dessus
c'est quoi cette histoire de carré
prévenez
un yaourt c'est qui c'est ouf he il y a
un yaourt moi j'achète des yaourts à 18h
à 19h je fais une overdose à la vanille
devant toi
admettons j'achète six yaourts les trois
premiers je les tue je me rends même pas
compte le 4e je regrette chaque
bouchée le 5e c'est juste pour me
prouver que c'est une mauvaise idée et
le 6e je me dis au moins comme ça il y a
plus de yaourt le problème il est réglé
voilà